Mikl: Tell us about...
Mikl: this was an assignment, I take it?
Fred: actually, this one, it was early on, and
Fred: I had to I had to keep getting these assignments.
Fred: So some unwary magazine said,
Fred: "Oh yeah go ahead shoot that."
Fred: I went to the Golden Gate Bridge office and said,
Fred: "I'm a photographer and this magazine wants to do a story on the bridge painters."
Fred: And they said, "Oh yeah, go out and see Joe.
He's the foreman. He'll fix you up."
Fred: Joe, thought I was really funny.
Fred: And I was crawling around the bridge for a couple of weeks. And they were all amused.
Fred: And after they saw me running around; a couple times they saved me from doing dangerous things.
Fred: I must say there were vantage points that I had...
Fred: Photography is all about getting your camera located at the proper viewpoint.
Fred: So that's what I was always about .
Fred: That's what made aerials and even underwater necessary.
Fred: But here, for instance, I was underneath the roadbed. Which was really the scariest place.
Fred: That little thing in the center is Alcatraz.
Fred: And when you're beneath the roadbed, there is a very odd sensation. Because you cannot see...
Fred: ...usually cannot see the horizon.
Fred: So you look down and, if there's a breeze, you see whitecaps moving underneath you.
Fred: And the sensation is that the bridge is falling over.
Fred: That is much scarier than being up on top.
Fred: Being up on top is achieved by...
in each tower there is a tiny electric elevator.
Fred: And it will accommodate two painters,
if they hold their lunch bucket on top of their head.
Fred: And it goes fairly slowly up to the top.
Fred: They've also discovered that you can get
two more guys on top of the cage,
Fred: if you remember to stop the elevator in time.
Fred: Otherwise it's not so good.
Fred: But the first time I got up on top,
Fred: I was so excited that I ran out
and started to run down a cable...
Fred: And one guy said, "Buddy, I think you better come back here. I want to give you a safety belt."
Fred: And I really appreciated their concern.